nouvelle vidéo dans une série de la
socio tech
c'est une série qui est consacré aux
travaux collaboratifs entre les élèves
aux classes inversée et à tout ce qu'on
peut faire avec les outils numériques
actuels pour faire de l'école une école
2.0 alors les outils google
évidemment c'est gratuit quand c'est
gratuit roduit c'est nous donc tous nos
données sont évidemment utiliser mais
malheureusement on n'a souvent pas les
moyens dans les écoles que pour
s'acheter des suites bureautiques
onéreuse et les outils google sont à la
fois gratuit très pratique est super
bien conçues pour des débutants mais il
propose suffisamment de fonctionnalités
pour que quand on veut progresser et
faire un petit peu plus on puisse le
faire je vous propose dans cette
première vidéo de découvrir peut être un
outil méconnu de google c'est google
drawings c'est un outil de dessin
vectoriel ne prenez pas peur c'est très
simple google drawings nous permet en
classe de réaliser des schémas des
schémas explicatifs des schémas fléché
mais aussi des logos par exemple des
petites communication visuelle google
drawings et finalement le cinquième
outils que nous utilisons de la suite
google car nous utilisons énormément le
traitement de texte google docs ce nous
utilisons abondamment le tableur google
shit l'application de présentation
google slide google forme ce qui nous
permet de faire des questionnaires en
ligne pour collecter des informations et
évidemment maintenant google drawings
tout de suite
rendez vous sur l'ordinateur pour la
prise en main de luz l'utilisation des
outils google nécessite quelques
prérequis que nous détaillerons dans des
prochaines vidéos mais je pars du
principe que pour cette première vidéo
tout le monde est capable d'ouvrir le
navigateur google chrome la manière la
plus facile pour accéder à google
drawing c'est aux autres outils google 2
tapez simplement dans la barre de
recherche
ce que l'on cherche
l'application s'ouvre vous voyez c'est
pas plus compliqué que cela
les doigts dans le nez évidemment il ya
d'autres possibilités pour accéder
facilement à cet outil
ça sera également détaillé dans de
prochaines vidéos
passons en revue les différents menus le
menu fichier ne vous permettra
d'exporter le document c'est à dire que
vous pour à l'enregistrer le publier sur
le web l'envoyer par email ou simplement
l'imprimé le menu édition et secondaire
menu affichage et secondaire le menu
insertion est assez important parce que
c'est là que vous allez aller chercher
les briques de votre production
c'est-à-dire que vous y trouverez les
différents éléments que vous pouvez
intégrer au document le menu format vous
permettra de formater la zone texte où
les textes intégré à la production le
menu réorganiser n'est pas important le
menu outils n'est pas important le menu
tableau vous permet d'intégrer des
tableaux directement dans la production
évidemment je peux ensuite écrire dans
ce tableau de manière plus intuitive que
ses différents menus
on a toutes les icônes qui sont
affichées ici sous ses menus ça va nous
permettre très facilement de construire
notre graphique
alors si on veut faire quelque chose qui
ressemble plus ou moins schéma fléché on
va d'abord bien sûr construire ces
différents réservoirs nous permettent de
symboliser des causes et des
conséquences vous connaissez la chanson
une fois que ces réservoirs sont
réalisés vous pouvez directement
impliqué dedans et intégrer votre texte
alors un schéma fléché nécessite des
flèches alors on va créer maintenant
d'être et vous voyez que dès que je
m'approche du rectangle du réservoir
quatre points apparaissent au milieu de
chaque côté en fait je me place
directement sur ces points je clique sur
ma souris et je peux facilement de
manière automatique reliés mais
différents réservoirs
donc c'est assez facile finalement à
réaliser vous allez me dire mais moi je
veux mettre des flèches avait regardé
ici dans le menu on peut s'amuser à
mettre des flèches on peut mettre des
points d'écart raid et losange s'est un
peu au choix vous admire mais la flèche
n'est pas assez grande n'est pas grave
vous pouvez ici l'augmenter comme vous
le souhaitez mais je veux une flèche
d'une autre couleur mais enfin allons-y
gaiement oui l'outil est très intuitif
moi je vous conseille personnellement 2
nous acclimater à cet outil en le
chipotant un petit peu comme je le fais
là une dizaine de minutes et vous verrez
après 10 minutes vous saurez faire plus
ou moins tout ce que vous voulez faire à
ce stade on n'a encore rien vu parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres outils qui
sont beaucoup plus performant que celui
ci pour créer tout ce que je viens de
faire le gros avantage des outils google
c'est tout ce qui est sauvegarde
modification de version et partage dans
un premier temps vous pouvez directement
changer le titre ici de votre schéma
fléché ce qui est intéressant c'est que
vous pouvez le faire sans devoir
sauvegarder alors que dans un fichier
par exemple microsoft on doit souvent
sauvegarder il faut ouvrir plein de
tableaux ben voilà ici c'est sauvegarder
tout simplement et les sauvegardes se
font automatiquement toutes les
modifications ont été enregistrés dans
drive drive c'est l'endroit où tous les
documents google sont conservés vous
allez me dire mais le problème c'est que
si je fais une erreur comment je fais
parce que ça ait déjà été sauvegardés
mais ils google a tout prévu
ici dans l'outil dans le menu fichier
vous avez l'outil historique des
versions et vous pouvez allez retrouver
les différentes versions qui ont été
modifiées par les utilisateurs
je dis bien les utilisateurs parce que
le gros avantage des outils google c'est
le mode collaboratif
plusieurs personnes peuvent travailler
sur le même document à différents
moments où en même temps
démonstration de retour sur le document
les plus attentifs d'entre vous auront
constaté l'apparition de cette petite
icône en haut à droite c'est un autre
utilisateur donc ça on le verra dans une
prochaine vidéo comment faire pour
partager un document pour qu'il ya
plusieurs personnes qui travaillent mais
évidemment ici l'autre tu d'autres
utilisateurs c'est moi qui me suis
connecté avec un autre terminal
quand même un peu de quoi devenir
schizophrénique donc les deux
utilisateurs peuvent vraiment interagir
imaginons que l'autre utilisateur veille
à modifier un rectangle mais vous voyez
sur l'écran que le rectangle
sélectionnés par l'autre utilisateur se
colore à son pourtour de rose qui est la
couleur attribuée par l'application à
l'utilisateur voyais bien ici le rouge
c'est que cet utilisateur lac est en
train de
modifier si j'avais plusieurs
utilisateurs différents il y aurait
plusieurs couleurs et chacun pourrait
modifier et on verrait leurs couleurs
finalement s'incruster sur l'écran
l'autre utilisateurs considèrent que le
réservoir serait mieux là est plus
intéressante en rouge que le texte ici
n'est pas correct et ainsi de suite donc
on peut vraiment collaborer et
travailler en ligne c'est la grande
force des outils google
je vous le montre ici de manière assez
sommaire on détaillera bien sûr tout
cela prochainement
lorsque je reviens dans mon menu fichier
pour consulter l'historique des versions
je vais constater cette fois que le
second utilisateur est bien mentionné
ici en couleur violette un les couleurs
peuvent changer et donc dans cette
version si on peut savoir qui a fait
quoi éventuellement si vous considérez
qu'une version ne correspond pas aux
attentes ou si des erreurs ont été
commises
vous pouvez toujours restaurer une
version précédente en cliquant sur le
bouton resterait cette version la
production est achevée comment la
partager le menu fichier comme je vous
l'aï dit tout à l'heure vous sera utile
hop on partage vous avez différentes
options de partage vous pouvez également
l'enregistrer dans différents formats le
format pdf le format jpeg qui est un
format image léger le format png qui
vous permettra de ne pas avoir un
arrière plan un fond blanc et qui vous
permettra de superposer votre production
sur d'autres choses existant déjà vous
verrez toujours par transparence les
éléments qui sont à l'arrière-plan en
apparaîtront sur votre avant-plan que
les réservoirs et vos flèches et tout ce
que vous avez fait sur votre google
drawings vous pouvez également le
publier sur le web directement ou
l'envoyer ici directement en pièce
jointe via un email le l'impression est
également possible évidemment toutefois
vous ne devez pas toujours ou
l'enregistrer comme je vous l'aï dit
tout à l'heure c'est ici que vous allez
retrouver les différents production les
différents fichiers que vous avez créés
c'est directement enregistrées sur le
cloud dans le drive ça fera également
l'objet l'objet je me répète deux
prochaines vidéos tout cela mais je vous
montre rapidement comme il s'agit de la
première vidéo ici on a tout
les google drawing ce qu'on peut créer
et qu'on a créé précédemment voilà ça
c'est un exemple j'avais fait pour
préparer cette vidéo merci l'avoir
regardé cette vidéo
r très bientôt tout tout tout tout